oui effectivement pauline c'est une
exposition qui fait parler parce qu'elle
est étonnante provocatrice et féministe
son auteur est une artiste franco
égyptienne et son travail est
passionnante parce qu'il est éminemment
politique
[Applaudissements]
installé au coeur de la nef du centre de
la création contemporaine
c'est une oeuvre gigantesque et
revendicatrice au sol pas moins de seize
mille cactus dressé est décrit par
l'artiste comme hostile derrière cette
symbolique sexuelle évidente
le message est politique ghada amer est
une féministe et ne s'en cache pas elle
se dit révolté par la domination du
monde de l'art par les mâles blancs et
anglo-saxons révolté de voir que les
femmes ont été exclus de la peinture
américaine de l'après guerre
si vous penchez un petit peu sur cette
histoire de l'art post seconde guerre
mondiale vous vous rendez compte qu'il
ya très peu de femmes qui ont été
reconnus comme des grands artistes de la
peinture
on parle beaucoup de frank stella de
josef albers de grands noms comme ça il
ya très peu de femmes donc pour elle
avec cette peinture il s'agissait de
mettre un doigt sur cette sorte
d'anomalie de l'histoire de l'art au
travers d'une oeuvre qui est éminemment
ironique et piquante autre combat outre
message politique cette fois
ghada amer utilise la peinture broder un
langage esthétique spécifiquement
féminin avec en fond des femmes plutôt
libérés issu du monde de la mode ou de
la pornographie et d'amères choisi de
représenter un modèle de femme qui
s'assume totalement pleinement dans sa
beauté dans sa sensualité
très souvent on a ce cliché sur les
féministes qui veulent en quelque sorte
terre la beauté des femmes comme si elle
n'était qu'un simple esprit et qu'elle
ne l'est pas de corps ou en tout cas
encore qu'on ne voulait pas mettre en
avant parce que cela pourrait être
péjoratif et bien ghada amer elle est
dans une logique est complètement
différente où elles assument cette
beauté cette sensualité du corps féminin
un travail qui dérange
un travail qui fascine ne le manquez pas
il est visible jusqu'au 6 janvier
[Musique]
bonsoir alain julien dray de la ferrière
bonsoir alors c'est vous qui avait
décidé de faire venir pour la deuxième
fois
ghada amer pourquoi mais qu'est ce qui
vous plaît tant chez cette femme cette
femme je sais pas mais en tous les cas
son oeuvre est extraordinaire elle est
partie de france après avoir fait une
exposition chez nous elle est devenue
mondialement connu et une star à new
york elle est repassée
elle a dit j'aimerais refaire une
exposition vingt ans après en france on
lui a dit ben écoute on a choisi en date
et puis elle s'est mise au travail voilà
c'est aussi simple qu'un deal entre
voisins alors l'exposition qui a fait
tant parler c'est celle qui est derrière
nous seize mille cactus vous votre
regard d'homme
vous dites quoi est-ce que vous vous
sentez valoriser ou plutôt agressé à
très honnêtement je m'en contrefiche
c'est pas pour ça que gala mère est là
maintenant il ya une résonance
importante avec tous les mouvements tout
l'état d'esprit qu'il est aujourd'hui
mais moi c'est pas ce qui m'intéresse
vraiment je ne sont pas agresser comme
homme parce que moi je m'occupe d'un
musée je m'occupe de montrer une artiste
quand même à cette politique derrière
sur masculine
bien sûr mais enfin comme comme lors de
sa conférence il a été très très poussée
dans ses retranchements féministes de la
part du premier rang elle a une réponse
qui montre que c'est vraiment une grande
artiste
oui oui je suis féministe oui d'accord
mais mais quand même ce qui m'intéresse
d'abord c'est la peinture
alors justement dans la deuxième salle
gadamer utilise la broderie pour faire
passer là aussi un message politique
alors d'un côté et la broderie de l'ocha
les femmes libérées on se dit mais quel
paradoxe dont 2 1 quand elle était jeune
on lui a dit un professeur d'arts
plastiques lui a dit sur le ton de la
provocation mais elle a pris très au
sérieux la peinture ma chère c'est pas
pour les femmes
donc elle a pris ça au premier degré au
camp nou noré plus au premier degré mais
les ailes et c'est d'abord une tête dure
et égyptienne c'est vraiment une femme
forte donc à la prise au premier degré
et donc qu'elle a décidé de peindre
juste des femmes juste autres et comme
un dessin qu'elle sait pas de peinture
et après sa peinture est l'apport de la
couleur et du mouvement c'est la
broderie
qui est un art réservé aux femmes mais
si cet artiste qui ne l'avait pas
provoquer comme ça c'est grâce à lui que
cette oeuvre elle a trouvé cette façon
détournée de faire encore aujourd'hui
une peinture magnifique merci beaucoup à
la juste une petite date c'est juste est
visible jusqu'au 6 2 janvier je sais
plus janvier voilà et il y as tout l'été
des animations pour les enfants très
sympathique et j'ai vu que vous pouvez
même venir la nuit ah ben oui ici c'est
tout c'est ouvert jour et nuit
ces balles l'oeuvre est disponible 24
heures sur 24 365 jours par an merci
beaucoup merci de rien